genau so ist es und dann ging es weiter
mit den reaktionen zu diesem rücktritt
nahe
ganz so weit ist es noch nicht aber mit
der ankündigung des endes von angela
merkel als sowohl cdu-vorsitzende als
auch als kanzlerin und zwar bei der
fraktionen und dem vorstand der
alternative für deutschland nämlich
alice weide der fraktionsvorsitzenden
und alexander gauland dem bundessprecher
kommen sind ja das ist natürlich ein
einschnitt ich habe mir die presse
kommen verweisen angehört nach 18 jahren
parteivorsitz man kann sagen die wähler
in hessen haben geschichte geschrieben
ja merkel muss weg ist damit zum teil
erfüllt es war immer der anfang vom ende
wenn ein parteivorsitz verloren geht
aber dazu wird frei weil noch was sagen
muss man abwarten wie sich eine
kanzlerschaft in diesen letzten drei
jahren ansieht und anhört es ist ein
erfolg der afd
das ist es hätte diesen tag ohne die afg
nicht gegeben
denn ohne die afg hätte es nicht diesen
druck jetzt auch innerhalb der cdu auf
frau merkel gegeben der ja
offensichtlich sehr stark war dass sie
eben nicht wieder kandidiert
entscheiden wird die frage der nachfolge
sein mehr
die cdu in die hand bekommt das geht uns
nichts an und die partei auch nicht das
muss die cdu für sich entscheiden aber
man kann vielleicht eine sache sagen es
würde mich sehr erstaunt wenn ein mann
der die partei verlassen hat um geld zu
verdienen jetzt sozusagen wieder käme da
gibt es ein altes indianisches
sprichwort man steigt selten an
derselben stelle in den fluss und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
parteien märz vor zeit dass er sie in
der not alleine gelassen hat deswegen
noch einmal auf die nachfolge kommt es
an
erst wenn sich die cdu innerlich so
gewandelt hat dass sie unsere bedenken
woraus unsere partei entstanden ist auch
mal intellektuell nachvollzieht
erst dann kann man langfristig und das
wird dann wahrscheinlich in ostdeutschen
bundesländern seien mal über eine
zusammenarbeit nachdenken
im moment ist das alles aufgabe der cdu
sich zu ändern
er ist im grunde alles schon gesagt die
hessischen wähler haben der
bundesrepublik ein ganz großen gefallen
getan das jetzt eben auch merkel
eingesehen hat dass hier im platz räumen
muss und wir erinnern uns merkel selbst
sagt seit jahren parteivorsitz und
kanzlerschaft gehören zusammen so jetzt
gibt's hier im parteivorsitz ab und wir
hoffen doch sehr dass sie dann auch ihre
kanzlerschaft möglichst bald abgibt denn
auch das wäre ein großer schritt für
unser land
das erwarten wir auch letzter konsequenz
von angela merkel was friedrich merz
anbelangt auch hier ein ganz wichtiger
punkt wer seine partei in schwierigen
zeiten verlässt und auch ihr gegenüber
illoyal ist und friedrich merz war
illoyal gegenüber der cdu man muss sich
die frage stellen ob das dann eben auch
die richtige personalie ist um diese
partei zu führen oder auch in die
zukünftigen wahlkämpfe hinein zu führen
das ist sache der cdu wir warten einfach
mal gespannt
april werden die koalition wenn
6 oder neuer vorsitzender getroffen wird
mit der cdu nur einfacher oder
politisch wäre na ja das ist ja erstmal
die frage die die cdu beantworten muss
also erst mal sieht man an dieser
entscheidung von herrn merz dass die
personaldecke enorm tennis weil
ansonsten würden sie ja nicht auf
jemanden zurückgreifen der die partei
erst mal verlassen hat und im regen hat
stehen lassen also da ist ja dann
anscheinend niemand dementsprechend
haben sie auch nicht das geeignete
personal um diese partei auch sage ich
jetzt mal in die zukunft zu führen also
ich sehe das bei herrn merz überhaupt
nicht das ist das eine und das andere
ist wir können es dass derzeit das hat
der gauner eben sehr schön gesagt uns
überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen da in
irgendeiner form über eine koalition
über eine mögliche nachzudenken eben
weil es programmatisch zu große
abweichung gibt wir sehen die cdu hat
sich programmatisch komplett
sozialdemokratisiert sie ist nach links
gerückt und von der personaldecke da ist
auch alles gesagt also wer auch mehr
zurückgreift der hat keine anderen ideen
also da muss schon was anderes kommen
dass wir darüber nachdenken als afd
ja ich habe ja immer gesagt wir hätten
es schwerer wenn herr sparen mit seinen
positionen parteivorsitzender würde
nur muss man deutlich sehen das
jedenfalls zu der zeit bin ich herr merz
noch kenne die menschen und die
spanischen position ähnlich sind das
heißt beide werden sich wenn sie
gegeneinander kandidieren
wahrscheinlich die stimmen wegnehmen
das ist die große schwierigkeit aber das
ist auch eine sache der cdu
wenn man sie so beobachtet ist
großes stück genugtuung dabei dass die
kanzlerin jetzt komplett abtritt woher
kommt
es ist partei ziehe der afg wir haben
damit wahlkampf gemacht frau merkel ist
eine kanzlerin und deren kanzlerschaft
dieses land aus unserer sicht völlig
abgerutscht ist sei es den
internationalen wohlstand indizes sei es
in der internationalen
wettbewerbsfähigkeit da werde da der
wurde erst die axt an die
energiewirtschaft gelegt durch die
energiewende die völlig überstürzt
gewesen ist jetzt an unsere
automobilindustrie dann die politik aus
unserer sicht völlig rechtswidrig der
offenen grenzen dann eine völlig
illegitim euro rettungspolitik die uns
an den rand des ruins bringt weil sparer
und rentner und die nachfolgenden
generationen eignet werden
das ist alles ich sag jetzt mal ganz
plakativ auf angela merkels mist
gewachsen und dementsprechend hat diese
genugtuung etwas damit zu tun dass
hoffentlich die zukunft besseres für
unser land bringt gleichen problem also
wie viele wähler
eine option wäre dann also hier voll
merkel ist zugleich auch ein problem
das kommt darauf an wie sich die figur
entwickelt
es kommt ganz darauf an wer die
nachfolge antritt und ob die cdu endlich
die politik von 2015 ändern oder ob sie
die weiter betreibt das würde ich heute
in die zukunft zu sehen wie nochmal wir
mischen uns nicht in die inneren
angelegenheiten der cdu ein auch da
kommt es darauf an wie frank frau kramp
karrenbauer dann mit dem merkel erbe
umgeht das kann man heute nicht
voraussagen
ja also das muss allein die cdu intern
lösen also ich sehe jetzt da nicht einen
großen programmatischen unterschiede
zwischen den beiden muss ich auch ganz
klar sagen also die cdu ist durch und
durch ein kernthema ist vom personal her
sei es von der programmatik also die cdu
muss sich komplett neu erfinden um auch
aus diesem wahlniederlagen lernen können